we're learning more about the risks of
the brain injury cte in athletes the
family of former nfl star demaryius
thomas revealed yesterday the signs of
cte when he died in december but it
isn't just football that carries risks
of brain injury here on cbs mornings
we've been looking into how the
condition could affect soccer players
yesterday retired u.s soccer star bruce
murray shared his neurological symptoms
and his fight to protect other players
this morning the family of another
player scott vermillion is talking about
his cte diagnosis which came after he
died nearly two years ago at age 44. it
was the first public diagnosis of the
disease in a former major league soccer
player first on cbs morning's chief
medical correspondent dr john lepuc
talked with vermilion's family who said
they learned about cte warning signs
after it was already too late
scott vermillion played five seasons for
major league soccer teams
including his hometown kansas city
wizards and dc united
he was also a devoted father to his two
children ava grace and braden what was
it like with your dad when you were
younger when you were growing up he was
quick-witted he was compassionate when
we were younger i would say he was more
like outgoing and just like happier as a
person at age five vermillion started
playing soccer from the very start he
was a standout how many goals would he
score i mean
by half time he'd have six or seven this
is where scott played it is scott's
father dave vermillion watched his son
reach the heights of elite soccer at age
26 an ankle injury ended his career but
scott seemed to be moving forward with a
new career in nursing looking back was
there a moment when you noticed that his
personality changed
yeah there was something off about the
way he was acting and did you ever link
the changes in his personality and in
his behavior to his soccer career no
dave vermillion says his son started
drinking too much and abusing the
painkillers he was taking for his injury
over the next decade scott tried rehab
several times but kept relapsing and
what would he say he would say dad i
have to take care of this myself
and i said well
you're not
taking care of yourself christmas at my
mom papas yeah
the change in vermilion's behavior was
obvious to his ex-wife cami and their
two children the things that he promised
that he would be there for
were like
life-changing big moments for us he said
he was going to go to braden's
graduation right and didn't show up
because he said he had work
how did you find out that he had died i
first found out it was on christmas in
december 2020 a friend found scott
vermillion in his house
he was not breathing i stepped out there
and he called me up and i
kind of knew like right away everyone
was crying vermilion had died from a
combination of alcohol and muscle
relaxers
the family began to suspect that the
game he loved had damaged his brain
they turned to dr ann mckee director of
boston university's center for chronic
traumatic encephalopathy or cte and that
wasn't normal for a 44 year old man dr
mckee found an abnormal protein
suggestive of cte in areas of
vermilion's brain that control memory
and organization of thought it's cte and
only cte that was the only thing that
was wrong with his brain dr mckee
believes concussions are not the only
cause of cte those balls are coming from
a great distance at a tremendous
velocity and that impacts the head and
causes
rapid acceleration deceleration and
rotation to the brain the professionals
have longer years of exposure but kids
kids who play high school sports they're
at risk for these changes dave
vermillion says during scott's many
years of playing soccer he had only one
concussion
substance abuse and unexplained
personality changes are early signs of
cte they can't control their brain and
they start isolating themselves from
people who care about them we see
hundreds of cases why aren't we doing
more to prevent this major league soccer
which governs the professional teams
vermillion played for declined our
request for an on-camera interview when
we asked about their protocols for blows
to the head that don't cause concussions
the league said it follows the most
up-to-date science and cited its medical
spotter program to identify potential
head injuries and removing from play any
player with a suspected head injury
for scott vermillion's family the report
from boston university brings some
answers
but also regrets
i wish
in those four years that
this was going on
i could have spent more time with him
and
been a little bit again more
compassionate there's definitely some
closure there though yeah
how so
just knowing the fact that his brain
wasn't like
processing the way a normal person would
process it and it's not like he
intentionally was doing this he wanted
to get help he wanted to be there for us
he was just sick and had this
disease
dr john lepux joins us right now
what is one of the biggest things you
want us to take away from this you know
the gift that the vermillion family is
giving us and that bruce murray and his
family gave us yesterday is awareness
they had no idea that the changes in
personality and memory and behavior had
anything to do with a sport and i think
if people are out there watching right
now if you are somebody involved in a
sport or you know somebody you notice a
personality change behavior change get
help see a doctor and and think about
going to a neurologist
is it about therapy is it about rehab of
the mind by get help what do you mean
well that first of all try to get a
diagnosis and we talked yesterday about
the importance of having a way of
diagnosing it before the person is dead
right now cte chronic traumatic
encephalopathy has to be on biopsy we
need ways of diagnosing it beforehand
and then maybe figure out ways of
preventing it thank you we appreciate
you